you know the only reason I came on to do
this episode with you charity I already
regret bringing you on and really key no
introduction needed what's up
usually it's appeared and we've brought
him on because he is the only person in
the world I can think of who would
appreciate this episode as much as I do
this is the props Department of BuzzFeed
and as you can see we have a variety of
chairs with us if you remember last
season I suggest it worth it cheers and
the finale this is one reason I want to
do season for one of the chairs
what is it serious we have sat together
in more different chairs then maybe me
with anybody else in my life
what kind of chair is the right chair
for you it's a far more complicated
question that you would think we're
doing chairs whoo today I wore that
lifestyle we're gonna be trying out the
chairs at three drastically different
price points to find out which chair is
the most worth it at its price how do
you taste-test a chair
the tasting will be done by our
backsides yes we're starting off in
California because we're gonna start off
with a place called California chair
they make your classic
office chair whoa arguably one of the
most important categories of chairs
sitting down eight hours a day you want
to find a chair that can actually make
that experience a little bit more
tolerable I'm Rick Henson president of
California chair and today we'll be
looking at the universal chair in fact
just introduced today today this day
actually I've been in the industry about
40 years when one day I just felt like I
could do this better a chair really is a
tool I've never heard a chair of being
described as a tool before it's designed
to support you and reduce workplace
injuries this particular chair the
universal chair where does it lie in
your range and what is its design thisis
the universal chair is our entry-level
chair it's made in the United States
starting at the floor is a full 60
millimeter heavy-duty casters standard
chairs 275 our Universal is standard at
300 pounds squeeze a class 4 gas lift
that's going to last forever it's worn
it forever we use 7 ply plywood I
density molded foam I think when I sit
on an office chair and I died my by
walls I've been hurt a little
over the day what is the design of your
cushion and how are you doing that to
eliminate some of those pains when you
build that seat you want to make it in a
compound curve like a tractor seat
farmers would farm in the field on a big
steel tractor seat in the shape of their
posterior that's the inspiration for the
design of your seats yeah you add that
feature when you start going up in
product line we all have a 100 200 and
300 an entry-level price point at the
middle and you get the top of the line
it's just like customizing a car right
most people sit eight hours a day for
five days a week and that chair is
tested the last for 12 years I want that
chair to last we're passionate about
recycling I'm a sailor and I see the
stuff that ends up in the ocean
I see plastic out there floating around
and I don't want to be a contributor to
that while our product may be twice what
you would pay at a big-box store you'll
buy that chair two three four times over
the life of what our chair would last
[Music]
usually we just sit down it's our eating
today the sitting is the eating three
two Oh first of all this is a little low
for me not like being this low add a
little bit on my arms one bar support
your butt is too far forward maybe you
want to slide your seat nice locked in
right now that I did this right look you
don't know what's right with it until
you know what's wrong with it
the most impressive thing to me the
amount of force that this back applies
it's very good it keeps me upright but
if I want to push back it lets me hmm
this is very comfortable I'm very happy
with it but I'm curious to try this is
the 200 with the tractor seat this looks
like a jelly doughnut oh yeah here my
whole seat goes back so I'm staying in
that same well seated position I want
you to try this chair are we posture
your pals
oh I would probably be distracted by how
great this chair is that working well
may be distracted for the first
your butt will thank you for it later
you've tried the universal chair now I
think we should try no yeah it's on the
market yet excited that's true yeah our
newest chair that I worked on and that's
our Sausalito chair and one thing you
notice right away is this back how it
moves whoa
this is relieving pressure on the spine
suggested list price on this chair is
$1,000 this is not the top end of the
market this will be 30% less than
anything close to this level three oh
[Music]
yeah I might as well be doing this salsa
in this damn chair no this feels like
nothing I've ever felt before
yeah it is broken down so that you can
actually have more flexibility because
usually it's just one back like these
just goes back and forth but this one
like I'm wearing a chair the concept of
the chair as a tool is very cool just
even this chair is three or more times
more expensive than the universal yeah
do you see yourself getting universal or
one of these this is the CEO chair
that's a good way of putting it after
your palace you gotta stop saying no
boom office chairs we did it know what
time it is so in England in Westminster
Abbey they have the coronation chair
which is a chair that is more than 700
years old whenever you deliver important
news to someone you always want to
present to sit down first yes
or sit down for this would you mind
taking a seat for a second you're gonna
be queen now do you think it's how it
went
yeah now we're off to another place in
Los Angeles called Bend where they are
bending the rules about how to pay the
chair
[Music]
hi my name is Gaurav Nanda and I am the
creator and founder of bend kids we're
called Bend goods and it's from the
bending of wire I was always interested
in mid-century wire furniture reinvent
it and make it something new we're gonna
be looking at the Lucy chair it's one of
our most well known chairs the Lucy
chair is one of the first chairs that we
created people are really kind of drawn
to that geometric pattern that's on the
back of the chair I think it was
something different why our furniture
wasn't really out there the way it is
today what can you tell us about the
Ellery selection I wanted something
bright and fun and I wasn't really
seeing it out there we believe that like
your phone should be fun when I look at
chairs I want to like it to invite me
into sitting into it and when I look at
a wire chair that's not the first thing
that comes in mind what we've done is
really taking a lot of care in the way
we are placing the wires we well the
wires really close to each other kind of
hug your body in a way that would be
comfortable so we do offer a variety of
different seat pads for that extra added
comfort and we can also do custom fabric
so if a customer wants a flower pattern
or something we can do that how much is
the Lucy chair cause the Lucy chair
starts at $450 the first word that comes
to mind is fun it looks like a chair I
would look at knots in it it looks like
a race car
oh yeah and of course they're in there
no chair yeah even immediately when over
he was like no remove the wallet to get
the full or did gonna forget that
three-two-one oh that is very
comfortable
oh yeah I'm actually really surprised
that I don't feel the wire has those
Pleasant springiness to the back
I like tears what I can like put on my
entire body on it you know like this
I'll try that
no way
oh you look like an old man as is
horrible something about sitting like on
a chair the way you're not suppose it on
the chair it's something I like to do
cuz nobody can tell you what's
comfortable that's right you can pretend
like you're eating at a dining room okay
and then reset your room oh oh okay
gotcha
you know it's a good test of a chair to
me if I was having dinner and I got to
dessert I kind of stretched like this a
little bit and it works in this chair
this is the chair that will impress your
guests it's a pop of color for your
apartment pow
it's like mesmerizing but not to a point
where you have a headache that's a good
way of putting it that very visually
satisfying I can be a very sweaty man
and sometimes if I'm sitting in a chair
I will leave a dewy mark any policies
but this clearly that would not be a
problem plenty of ventilation it's still
warm out that's a great set you know
you're ill sit down kind of guy if you
lie on these chairs all right I gotta
say that place actually changed my
perspective on chairs you can think of
purchasing as a chair as both getting a
sculpture for your home and a thing to
use somewhere or is that that is a
foolish statement oh I don't really love
a chair that you could hose off you know
that's it for Bend but before we go to
the next place chair factor factor
chair fat according to architect V told
Rybczynski oldest chair on historical
record dates back to between 2800 and
2700 BCE the chair in question is part
of a sculpture featuring a musician
playing a harp while seated on a four
legged chair so all of the things that
humans can do for entertainment and I
think of the oldest things music okay
also sitting yeah I would argue is kind
of a form of entertainment highly
underrated form of entertainment
hey let's all sit down and just talk to
one another human nature actually it's
instinct show it's like breathing so
where are we heading to now so go to
Stockton California up to c8 SuperDuper
awesome rocking chair is it the rocking
chair really the ultimate chairs oh and
what is the approximate price point it
is $92 Wow
yeah that is one year of rent he was
pretty much no limit to how expensive a
chair could be some may even say the
earth is the most expensive
I'm Jarrod Reston and we're in the J
rust in furniture studio and today I'm
gonna be showing you guys the modern
rocking chair which is my take on this
American classic what drew you to
working with wood there was something
about using this natural material to
create a functional object that becomes
part of the family the wood and the
design aren't fighting too much for
attention it's like more of a harmony I
wanted to build something that you could
develop a relationship kind of from
cradle to grave from start to finish how
do you make a rocking chair the the
first step is obviously wood selection
I'm looking specifically for grain
patterns that match the shape of the
elements if you've got this curved piece
and the grain is following that curve
it's gonna want to stay in that curve
I've been developing this slatted seat
design since 2002 and trying to get you
know the lumbar just right and tweaking
the heights and trying to make it as
universally comfortable for as many
people as possible
you've got the seat projecting out and
it gives us weightless quality I thought
a lot about how the slats would be
fastened ultimately I decided I wanted
the piece to seem classic so I decided
to use traditional slotted screws there
is an insert nut embedded in the frame
so I can use a machine screw with a
finer thread pitch and one fussy detail
when using slotted screws is to clock
them you're lining up the slots so they
all line up in a similar way how much is
the rocking-chair
9800 that is purely reflective of the
time it takes trust me I'm not getting
rich on this chair it's just priced so
that I can keep doing this
are you ready to sit in it
no leave a player like LeBron all-star
you put him on any team and he just you
build the team around LeBron you get an
apartment you put the chair down that is
the centerpiece of the room I'm gonna
build my room around the idea of this
rocking chair I'm not gonna lie I
thought that analogy was going nowhere
but that's a great point thank you this
is the LeBron of chairs it's smoother
than you think it'll be oh well because
it looks like a oh hi buddy
new co-host okay bye
[Music]
give me the giggles that we that hot
chicken the same kind of high that I got
from eating hot chicken I just got from
sitting in this chair for a new chair to
actually make you stop and and chuckle
and say like what the heck one thing I
just realized that I wasn't realizing
the pressure on my buttocks right in
your back lower back but yeah I don't
feel that all of the seams are perfect
on like you touch the ones down here
touch the ones up here along here it's
just like uniformly great around the
whole thing I know that these screws are
straight behind me that's that's yeah
and you can't see that while you're
sitting in the chair unless you bought
two of them would you buy two of these
so that you could rock out with a friend
you gotta have to get two you kind of
have to just all of my tension drips off
my body your facial expression it's like
you're achieving nirvana slowly I've
never seen you this satisfied and we've
eaten a lot of things that were very
good I really like the idea of Crale the
grave and then a legacy piece that you
can then hand to your kid this is a
delightful experience I don't want to
get up that's that's when you know this
is us in 40 years or us now just want to
say thank you Andrew you have done a
better job than any of us expected all I
had to do was sit true but you have been
nothing but an angelic cherub you carry
the torch well I was the cherry on top
with not a chair in the world and so
Andrew which chair one of the most worth
it to you it's price
believe it or not but I think I have to
go with Jared Russell's rocking chair
you know it's expensive but he puts a
lot of hours into it and I could also
put a lot of hours into it by sitting in
it I was gonna choose Jared Ruston then
I asked myself the question am I going
to buy one
and the answer is to me right now in my
life no so how can that be my worth to
the winner
I do aspire to buy one but I'm unable
now been to come into the world and try
to change the chair game I admire him
for it but my worth the winner goes to
California chair it's every kind of
chair you want it to be and I can afford
it right now it's the right tool for the
job then that's that's right Annie or
that winner Wow
thanks for watching we'll see you next
week tiny houses
[Music]